welcomewelcome
lots of talk about will talk about the
possibility of Republican civil war I'll
tell you why that doesn't mean that
Donald Trump is any better of a person
then very few of you probably thought he
was I'll take your questions I'll tell
you about what's going on on the program
tomorrow what else
400,000 subscribers that's a big deal
and we have had actually the last 72
hours or so since we hit 400,000
subscribers on YouTube
we're almost at 402 thousand already we
have seen the last 72 hours have been
probably the biggest for us on YouTube
over the last two plus months I would
say so that's good because there have
been you know there's been this thing
going on
not the YouTube ad pocalypse ad
pocalypse started at the end of March
2017 which crushed our revenue but then
the new thing has been the status called
limited ads when videos get limited and
in principle there there used to be two
statuses for videos on YouTube if they
were either monetized or they were not
monetized based on the content and some
time ago YouTube established this third
status which is ads are running but
there may be few ads and what that
translates to for most videos is is no
ads like strictly speaking it's not
monetized but just no ads run and I am
convinced that although officially that
only impacts the revenue that a video
makes I am convinced that limited ads
are also less discoverable and less
likely to be recommended like if you're
watching a Young Turks video or a Sam
cedar video it would be pretty common
that a recommended video on the side
would be a david pakman show video or a
Kyle kolinsky video or whatever I am
pretty convinced based on the numbers
that we've been seeing over the last
couple up and till a couple months ago
where the recovery started is that ads
ad limited videos are also less likely
to be recommended by YouTube so it's
been all bad I mean really I wish that
there was some positive things
talk about but the only positive thing
is we have had 72 really good hours on
YouTube and we had a really solid live
stream on now I don't even remember if
it was Sunday or Monday evening and a
lot of people ask questions and
contributed and all sorts of stuff so
anyway we're trying to focus on the
positive and along those lines I'll
welcome you into the live stream if it's
your first live stream the live streams
are live as the name suggests which
means that yes if you ask questions or
send comments through super chat or
stream labs I will be able to answer
them for you what am I talking about
well that's number two super chat is on
that's the dollar sign at the bottom of
the YouTube chat window you can use it
to send questions I'll answer them you
can use it to send comments I will read
them and react to them but just so you
know when you send a super chat YouTube
takes 30% of that revenue you send a
dollar they take 30 cents there is a way
to circumvent that which is by using the
top link in the live stream description
which goes to stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show works the same way a
super chat but they take like three
percent which is a lot less than 30
percent that's for sure new members and
patrons will get live thank-yous and
shout outs during the live stream those
two respectively or at david pakman.com
slash membership and patreon.com slash
david pakman show we've had a nice
little uptick in patrons and patreon
dollars over the last three days we're
up to 1958 patrons and that's a
fantastic thing and patreon is just it's
such a great platform and they just
actually release this is very cool
patreon just raised a bunch of money and
they are now just yesterday I think it
was or maybe today I got an email hard
to keep track when there's so much else
going on I think it was yesterday or
maybe today doesn't matter they sent out
an email to creators about new app
integrations thanks jag antic I'll get
to your question momentarily new app
integrations where we can use patreon to
interface with our WordPress website to
allow patrons access
to certain pages that are for patrons
only
integrations with patreon and MailChimp
which is the email system that we use
anyway a whole bunch of nerdy stuff that
I think will be really good for you so
in any case 1958 patrons I can assure
you if you make a patreon contribution
you will be thanked by me on the
livestream and it would be great to get
to 1975 1975 patrons is our target for
today
that's only 17 of you I think it is very
very doable and lastly please don't
troll don't troll in the chat people
want to be here they want to talk about
politics they want to talk about news
they want to talk about all sorts of
different stuff that's going on don't
troll the trolling is bad and yeah I
don't know what else to say
there are moderators monitoring the chat
who have been deputized by me to get the
get the trolling out okay so that is
that let me talk briefly about my
thoughts on Republican civil war or
throughout the week we have been
bringing you a variety of different
stories related to Trump's battles with
Republicans John McCain has been going
very hard against Donald Trump very very
hard and we can talk about McCain's
politics and I don't agree with a lot of
his political positions but he doesn't
seem to be taking any BS from Donald
Trump at this point Donald Trump and
senator bob Corker a Republican senator
got into it earlier this week we had a
great clip that I think has close to
200,000 views at this point about that
and that is another intra Republican
battle that is going on Jeff Flake Jeff
Flake took to the house under the Senate
floor rather and the other Republican
senator from Arizona alongside John
McCain Jeff Flake said I'm getting out
I'm not doing this anymore
and I'm getting out and that's it and it
has to do with Donald Trump so there's a
few different thoughts about the
implications of this Republican civil
war the top line is Trump's never really
been a Republican and whether it's the
Republican Party or the Democratic Party
Donald Trump doesn't really have a
natural fit within the two-party duopoly
because he doesn't really know anything
about politics he doesn't really know
anything about
so many of the of the areas that a
president that an elected official needs
to know about to even have clearly
defined positions and I've joked around
a lot while we've been covering Donald
Trump for the last you know nine months
at this point plus the campaign I've
joked around the guy doesn't really have
a political philosophy other than greed
and self enrichment and self
aggrandizement and just kind of
appearing to be the big man so it's
obvious that ultimately he was going to
have a battle with the Republican Party
it would be happening with the
Democratic Party the difference is and
if I were a Republican insider my
concern would be not just Trump but the
fact that their electorate was stupid
enough to be bamboozled into voting for
Donald Trump right this was not an open
seat where there were no Republicans
running in the primary and Donald Trump
just snuck in Donald Trump defeated 16
other Republican candidates now you
could make the case that if there had
been fewer Republican candidates Donald
Trump would not have been able to pick
off enough support in the early
primaries to stay in it and ultimately
win I don't know that I buy that I
genuinely don't know that I buy that
because the non Trump support could have
consolidated around a Republican
candidate as they dropped out and it
didn't happen so if I'm a Republican my
concern isn't what's Trump going to do
although I would be concerned about that
and I would also be concerned about how
his Trump going to impact my reelection
chances the chances in 2018 and in 2020
but I would be concerned about the fact
that your voters 80% of whom still
support this guy were so easily tricked
drain the swamp he's filling the swamp
he just decided not to deport a fugitive
who to China after finding out that the
guy is a moral hago member he just set
up a 10 minute briefing on a hurricane
in Texas even though the rest of the
trip was all fundraising for re-election
in order to be able to get you taxpayers
to pay for that trip and the air travel
and every all the expenses associated
with that trip so there's been no draw
of the swamp there has been none of it
and if I am just somebody like Jeff
Flake who is a pretty hardcore
Republican not a guy I we would agree
with politically I would be concerned
that his voters were tricked so easily
into voting for who a clueless con man
with no knowledge of anything period
okay so that's my thought on the
Republican civil war situation that may
be building tomorrow on the Friday show
I will be talking about the 2020 census
now it sounds so boring right the census
David what would the census could be
there could be nothing more boring I've
been talking about the census for years
because the census is hugely important
and we are squarely on track to
completely screw up the 2020 census
which has major implications
implications for redistricting and
gerrymandering implications for how
thanks real to boots here I'll get to
Super chats and stream laps questions
momentarily the census is used to
determine how federal funds should be
distributed to all sorts of program very
long list the census really matters
number one in 2010 Congress said the
next census in 2020 can't cost any more
than the 2010 census in
inflation-adjusted dollars or in nominal
dollars in nominal dollars
so just accounting for inflation we
would have a larger number of nominal
dollars needed in 2020 but we also have
a bigger population we have a bigger
population today than we did in 2010 and
we'll have a bigger population in 2020
than we do today and if you don't have
more money when you have more people to
count you're gonna have a bad time and
in addition to that Donald Trump has cut
census funding that Census Bureau
director quit there's none right now
there's not even a nominee a key aspect
of a census running smoothly is that the
Census Bureau has a director and one has
not even been nominated yet so tomorrow
on the program I'm gonna get deep into
seeing if I have a book here
about this I don't I'm gonna get deep
into tomorrow on the program the
upcoming [ __ ] show as someone said in
the chat that the next census is
scheduled to be so prepare yourselves
because it's going to be bad and it's
gonna be it's the most constituencies
will be negatively affected by a crappy
census some political interests will
benefit from it but not not that many
let's start with stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show gigantic made a $5
contribution there what are your
thoughts on the kyle kolinsky debate on
the drunken peasants you should go on a
debate please stop pay walling pat you
know I only saw about 90 to 120 seconds
of Kyle's debate on the drunken peasants
and the 90 to 120 seconds that I saw
so obviously exposed that Kyle was
debating some clueless dude I couldn't
even tell you who the guy was I have no
idea how the debate came together I mean
I know almost nothing just people
tweeted it to me I looked at two minutes
and then said Kyle's wiping the floor
with this guy I don't really need to
watch any more of it so you know I'm
always up for debating as long as it
makes sense right I mean people people
write in and they say David I'm an
incredibly articulate political debater
and I wanted to bait you on your program
and I say oh call in call in and during
live calls and it's a disaster like they
can't even get a question out with
without face-planting so I'm willing to
debate but let's establish why we're
debating let's establish what the
parameters are the topic the duration so
that it doesn't become a mess and
gigantic following up with a $2.00
stream lapse contribution saying type 1
in the chat if you want to see David
debate people okay so there's that and
people are free to type type any number
you want really but you're certainly
allowed to type one if that's the number
you like Paul lien has sent a 22 dollar
super chat with no comment Paul you are
now the top contributor on today's live
stream and twenty two dollars and one
cent is the challenge number that Paul
has established
very much Nick K no 11 has sent a $2.00
super chat was Trump firing Comey an
obstruction of justice listen you're
asking me a legal question right
obstruction of justice is really an
issue of legality I'm not a lawyer what
I can tell you is that Trump admitted
the purpose of the firing was to get
James Comey away from the Russia
investigation to me colloquially
speaking that is trying to get in the
way of the proper carriage carrying out
of justice so I would say in layman's
terms it absolutely was Nick the real
tuba tear has sent a $2 super chat how
do we get rid of the electoral college
it's going to be tough it's going to be
tough for a couple reasons number one
you can do it through a constitutional
amendment you need something like 2/3 of
the House and Senate and three-quarters
of the states to agree unlikely however
there is another option which is the
national popular vote interstate complex
and what that is if you get enough
states it's always hard to come up with
a sentence to explain this you need 270
electoral votes to become president of
the United States if you can get enough
States together who which in total have
270 or more electoral votes to agree
that they will give their electoral
votes to whoever wins the popular vote
not whoever wins their state you
effectively have a national popular vote
I think that that's a more direct path
to abolishing the electoral college then
a constitutional amendment gangster talk
has sent a $5 super shot you know I'm
curious anytime I hear the phrase
gangster talk I'm reminded of elegant
Elliot often from the Howard Stern Show
who's not been allowed on the Howard
Stern Show because he's not allowed by
Sirius XM security in the building after
an outburst he had several years ago on
the program he used to always say
gangster talk so whenever I see that I'm
reminded of elegant Elliot off and it'd
be interesting to hear whether that's
the reference anyway the $5 super chat
from gangster talk do you think the
Young Turks has
gotten a free pass on YouTube D
monetization I have I want to be super
clear I'm willing to answer this
question but I want to be absolutely
clear I have no inside information on
this I could not tell you whether the
answer is yes or no
EDA when I saw how quickly the Young
Turks got ads back before anybody else
had them myself included my instinct was
that there must have been some kind of
white listing of The Young Turks but I
have absolutely no independent knowledge
of that whatsoever I really couldn't
tell you so the answer would be it
certainly seemed that way certainly seem
that way let me do a couple thank-yous
okay membership is the number one
funding source for the David Pakman show
and the way to sign up is at david
pakman.com slash membership members get
the bonus show they get a daily
commercial free audio and video feed of
the show it's a very long any number of
member benefits are available and we
just had a new sign up from David Mandel
David Mandel has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership
achtung not to take advantage of the 40
percent discount code which is I voted
17 you can take advantage of that if you
want
thanks very much to David and I also
have a new patron to thank I want to
thank David bishop who has signed up for
five dollars a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and that's a
beautiful thing that's a beautiful thing
we are now at 1959 patrons I believe or
is that not right we started the evening
at 1958 and we're still at 1958 even
though David made a pledge we must have
lost somebody gee that's depressing
isn't it geez we're trying to grow the
number somebody just cancelled their
patronage that that is seriously
depressing folks that I can tell you for
sure okay
so in any case more thank yous up coming
hopefully hopefully more thank yous up
coming we have another stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show contribution
it is from 280z turbo who says anyplace
is to have Sam cedar on the show I'm a
big fan of both of you guys you know I
was just hanging out with Sam in Las
Vegas last week had a great time and
there's no particular plans you know the
thing is Sam and I on each other's shows
we've done it before it's not a great
fit because we both have similar roles
on our programs where I think it's much
better for us to be interviewing experts
in some particular field or academics or
whatever when we interview each other I
don't think it's that interesting
although I would be interested in
talking with Sam about his battle with
Jimmy Dore that's going on okay and I am
going to be addressing people have been
writing in saying David are you on are
you taking aside in the Sam cedar versus
Jimmy Dore battle within the left as
some are calling it that's taking place
and I am NOT neutral on that I want I
don't want to suggest for a moment let's
dispel this notion to take a page from
little Marco Rubio a phrase from little
Marco Rubio I am going to be probably
next week during our audience question
segment I am going to be dispelling the
notion that I am even remotely neutral
on Sam cedar versus Jimmy Dore I'm
anticipating a total [ __ ] show I know
from looking Sam has a comment on his
channel from yesterday or today where he
addressed this issue and it is getting
disliked to oblivion and I think that no
matter which side of the issue of the
battle I come down on half people aren't
gonna like it and I am ready to do that
I am NOT going to be staying neutral on
this and that's next week
that is next week unless someone sends
like if someone were to send a crazy
super chat amount like if someone sent
that 250 dollar super chat maybe I would
address right now which side of that I'm
on but you know we plan the show out
some app elements of the show ahead of
time and
that is planned for next week so only a
major just like an obscene stream labs
or a super chat contribution or getting
to 2,000 patrons tonight would get me to
discuss that today okay
gigantic has sent a dollar stream labs
contribution and he wants me to answer a
question that he is asked in Spanish and
for people who don't know
gigantic who sometimes goes by the name
Clark or sometimes David's girlfriend or
sometimes I think Louis Motamedi note on
Pakman gigantic has a lot of usernames
he asks questions in Google translated
Spanish and they're always grammar
abortions and then I have to struggle
through it and then translate it to
English so here's this question dumbness
done to fidget spinner the Sophia's
where my fidget spinners or the fidgets
spinner sort of events or things I had
planned the fidget spinner is right here
but I don't have anything planned for it
right now
khadiyah this year case Australia pet or
no podía which means I wanted to say I'm
from Australia but I would not be able
to again weird translation from Google
Translate le problema es pad es me Yolo
yo yo quiero piensa que me quiera
tambien estaba pensando que quieres n't
ok this is getting very very graphic
gigantic apparently Pat is gigantic
Idol and he loves Pat and he wants
sexual relations with Pat so I'm not
able to help which was the main question
there those should really cost more than
a dollar I don't know how that got in
there for a dollar
Christina sent the dollar stream Labs
contribution what did you make for
dinner after the last live stream I
don't remember I don't remember what I
made for dinner after the last live
stream but tonight I made a lemon pepper
chicken with broccolini and sweet
potatoes and it was delicious
it was delicious and nutritious that
and say for sure okay I'm all I'm all
distraught by that Spanish Pat loving
stream lapse contribution I don't even
know I had a whole agenda and I don't I
don't even know where to go next here
okay we're where did I want to go next
okay the race an IQ video the race and
IQ video has been fully pre produced
okay we are going to be I'm recording
narration for the race and IQ video
tomorrow I've been trying to get to it
this week it's just been insanely busy
and I will be recording it tomorrow and
then segment producer Noah Ferguson is
going to be doing the editing on it and
then we will slot it in to our within
the interview schedule it's probably
going to be a two-parter because I
anticipate it will be anywhere from
twenty twenty to twenty-five ish minutes
long so we'll probably do it in two
parts on the broadcast show and put the
race and IQ video on YouTube all in one
piece for everybody so that that is
upcoming for people wondering about that
gangster talk cent a $2.00 super chat
where you turned by the transgender
Playboy Playmate Playmate I'm gonna
interpret this as was I turned on by the
transgender Playboy Playmate plain
Playboy Playmate I don't know anything
about a transgender Playboy Playmate I
cancelled my playboy subscription when I
was 8 years old
I only subscribed to it up until I was 8
and then I cancelled because the
articles just got not as good so I
couldn't tell you anything about it
gangster talk I don't know what I don't
know is that even true does anybody know
there was a transgender Playboy Playmate
I don't know a thing about it but I
don't know I guess it's an interesting
story I'm guessing if true that that
would be the first transgender Playboy
Playmate although maybe not I don't know
I don't know what the history of that of
that story yes as you can probably tell
I'm also on today's on tomorrow's Friday
program we will be answering questions
about cryptocurrency and whether I have
any judgment on people who buy
cryptocurrency but I buy cryptocurrency
so if I'm judging people who buy it I'd
have to judge myself and I do that all
the time so that's possible I'm going to
talk tomorrow in a little more detail
than we have over the last few weeks and
there was a story today related to this
what can be done to prevent mass
shootings what can be done to prevent
individual gun homicides and gun deaths
what types of types of things would work
what types of things wouldn't work
that's gonna be on tomorrow's Friday
program and also I have a really good
Ghent youger story I've not told that I
don't think I've told the story before
publicly but I was asked an audience
question which we will answer tomorrow
which was am i when if I'm in a coffee
shop or a library or in a public place
if someone says hey can you watch my
laptop for a second or can you watch my
stuff for a second am I willing to do it
and I will answer that but I also have a
really good Genki ogre host of The Young
Turks story related to being asked to
watch other people's stuff I'll be
telling that tomorrow on the Friday show
but intent peek behind the curtain if
you want access to the Friday show now
and you want to hear the junk you gur
story just become a member because the
member show will be uploaded early
before the Friday show goes public so
check that out david pakman.com slash
membership ok other questions the real
two bits here two dollars what's going
on with US relations with Ukraine I have
no idea I have not been following it but
it would be very interesting because
we've seen we've seen the change in the
relationship with Russia I guess under
Donald Trump although to describe it as
a change in the relationship is almost
weird but how has that impacted the
relationship with Ukraine I don't know
the answer and I'm gonna make a note of
that topic because it is an interesting
one making a note and I will look into
it for you over at Stream labs.com slash
the David Pakman show
Yesenia Moreno has sent a dollar
question
asking am I going to interview voters
during the midterm elections yeah so we
don't do too much man-on-the-street
stuff where I go out and talk to voters
the last time we did it was I think
during the primaries yeah because on
Election Day we were in studio
broadcasting live so I think on the day
of the Massachusetts primary in 2016 and
the New Hampshire primary
I interviewed voters and it was
interesting I think and we don't do that
too much so the question is will I be
doing it during the midterm elections I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that but I do think it would be very
interesting to ask voters specifically
was your vote today influenced by the
presidency of Donald Trump in other
words are you voting because Trump is
president and you normally don't vote if
you're voting for Republicans how was
your vote influenced by Trump etc so I
think that there's that's an interesting
idea
Yesenia and and we should do it we
should do it and we'll try to line it up
or at least get some correspondents out
on the street talking to voters because
I I have many questions for voters
particularly for the 35% that still
support Donald Trump so yeah we're gonna
try to do that impeach Trump has sent a
to New Zealand dollar super chat with no
question or comment how much is to New
Zealand dollars to US dollars I don't
know what the exchange rate is it's a
dollar 37 us all right I had no clue
what the relative exchange the exchange
rate was for New Zealand dollars over
its stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show David bishop
has sent a $2 contribution saying can
you say I love the fake podcast David's
awesome also loved the show
glad to be a new patron well I said it I
don't know if the fake podcast is your
podcast David but you got me to say
congratulations gigantic has sent a $3
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show contribution thoughts on whether
Bernie Sanders can still win the 2016
election h a ghost
it still wind that's clever that's very
very clever I I have no clue whether
this is true
AJ Goodman doesn't like me and I've
interviewed AJ Goodman and after I
called him out for you know what I don't
even remember what it was I think it was
something relating to that Seth Rich
conspiracy theory he did like ten videos
about me it was crazy every day he was
streaming I did one video about the guy
and then one sort of follow-up
responding to him and he must have done
eight or ten videos he was talking about
me on live streams it was very weird he
became strangely fixated with me someone
wrote to me the other day and told me
that Tim black has had a separation from
H a Goodman because H a Goodman came out
as a trump supporter I am being very
clear I have no clue if that's true a
viewer told me that and it struck me as
odd and then I realized I don't even
care enough to Google it but if that's
true that's very very odd and
interesting very very strange gangster
talk has sent a $2 super Chad Trump
diddled me at 13 he should be impeached
listen it seems that he has sexually
harassed many women so if that's true I
encourage you to contact the authorities
I personally don't find it super funny
to joke about sexual assault
particularly when there's already so
much stigma and so many people that are
unwilling to report sexual assault that
they've suffered so it's not something I
would joke about Nick Matt Cecotto
has sent a five-dollar super chat how do
we fight the border wall and support
immigration reform the process needs
streamlining how do we fight the corrupt
TSA ok last part first I have no idea
how to fight the TSA I don't know as
much about TSA corruption I know about
Tiye TSA impotence 95% of banned items
that are attempted to be snuck by the
TSA in internal tests of their methods
get by out of every 20 test items that
they try to get by 19 get by it's not
great ok how do we fight the border wall
have you been paying attention I don't
know that the border wall is close to
happening unless I've missed some news
in the last two hours the border wall
that supposedly Mexico was going to
pay for it's not exactly moving forward
quickly okay so I don't know that I
would do too much now immigration reform
is a more complicated one and you know I
at the base level we've got to elect the
people that have the views we agree with
on immigration reform but it's much more
complicated than that particularly with
all the special interest groups that are
involved
Raymond mccabe has sent a $2 super chat
what are your thoughts on congressional
dish podcast by Jen briny very good
podcast I've entered interviewed Jen
many times she hasn't been on for a
while we should have her back she has a
podcast called congressional dish and
she breaks down bills that are actually
being proposed and sometimes passed by
the House and Senate she's very good
good podcast I can say that for sure
okay any ghost has sent a twenty dollar
super chat thank you very much I'm not
sorry not super chat stream Labs
contribution how closely do you agree
with the views of Noam Chomsky and do
you ever worry as I do that there will
be nobody of commensurate knowledge
sophistication and insight to fill his
shoes when he dies I am NOT a fanboy
personally and John you know there's a
couple there's a little bit people like
to talk about the split on the left like
Sam cedar battling Jimmy Dore but there
is and that's I'll talk about that as I
said next week unless we get some major
super chat demanding I address that this
week I have never been a sham ski
ultimate fanboy and there are people in
the audience who are I think that Noam
Chomsky has very interesting things to
say about the effect of media on culture
and his analyses of media in many ways I
find very very interesting I don't think
it'll come as a surprise to many in the
audience that I am not completely
aligned with Noam Chomsky's views on the
israeli-palestinian conflict and I do
believe that he has a lot of very
valuable things to say on lots of issues
but I've never become part of the
Chomsky sort of cult of personality the
way some other people have Brian has
sent a dollar stream Labs contribution
any good book any books you'd recommend
that
give a good overview of economic
theories many books so I've said before
that I think it's useful to start
learning economics as if neoclassical
Chicago School Keynesian rational actor
efficient markets hypothesis economics
were completely accurate ok because in
order to understand critiques of that
economic theory I think it's important
to understand what is the sort of idea
of how economics work in most economics
departments at universities and colleges
around the country so and some people
might be shocked by this
check out Thomas soles basic economics
Thomas soul is a sort of I don't want to
unfairly characterizing but basically a
right-wing economists I don't know that
I want to call them a supply-side ER
necessarily but certainly what we would
consider a right-wing economists but I
still think it's a good idea to start
with basic economics because it at least
tells you what the standard is that some
people pretend is the reality of
economics you can read Keynesian stuff
and read Milton Friedman and that type
of material then what about reading a
little bit of Marx right to find out an
alternative theory and I am NOT a
Marxist I've made that clear but I think
it's useful to read Marx you don't
really need to read Das Kapital you can
read summary these you can get cliff
notes you can get a very short
introduction to Marxism if it exists I
assume it does in the very short
introduction series which is excellent
by the way I mean an excellent excellent
series I just bought the very short
introduction to rhetoric and I have a
couple others on my list that I want to
read and then start to dig into
critiques of standard economic theory
you can get books by Richard Wolfe my
former economics professor I think he
has a book let me just tell you for sure
yeah Richard Wolfe has a book that he
wrote along with Steven Resnick who
sadly has passed away dynamic duo of
economics professors at the University
of Massachusetts both formerly Steven
Resnick
because he passed away a few years ago
wolf because he retired and now teaches
at the new school they have a book
called Marxian versus neoclassical so
after you've read some neoclassical and
you've read some Marx now you can
actually read a comparison of the two
and then read some behavioral economics
read Daniel Kahneman read dan Ariely and
those are related to economic theory in
different to different degrees but they
will make you understand that the entire
rational actor farce that that standard
economics teaches us is bogus and I
would also recommend I just finished it
yesterday and I'm gonna be recommending
it on the program tomorrow irrational
exuberance by Robert Shiller it's not a
general economics book it deals
specifically with bubbles and stock
markets and housing bubbles and housing
markets but it really does a lot to
explain to us that the efficient market
hypothesis is an absolute and total myth
and that's part of neoclassical economic
theory so I think that that would be
useful to read as well David Bishop has
sent a $2.00 stream Labs contribution
what are your thoughts on the foreign
policy expansion among the left and the
isolationism that seems to be taking
over the Republican Party because of
alt-right nationalist ideology this
question requires a lot of defining of
terms but let me say generally I am not
in favor of or against foreign policy
decisions merely because they conform or
break from a general ideology like
isolationism or like neoliberal
spreading of democracy or whatever right
so I tend to take a much more pragmatic
approach and one that typically falls
more in the middle I don't believe that
extremist isolationism make sense I
don't believe that the United States is
can be or should be the policeman of the
world I think that we live in an
interconnected world a smaller and
smaller world because of globalization
and I think that there are no simple
answers when we say
the US should never get involved unless
we're about to get nuked right that
would be an extreme isolationist view or
anywhere that there's a humanitarian
crisis if the US has the ability and
resources the US should get involved I
don't believe that either right so I
think that we really need to look at
individual foreign policy decisions
first and then think about the broader
context in which we would be making
those decisions 280z turbo has sent a $2
stream lapse contribution will senators
corker McCain and flake cause older
traditional conservatives to reconsider
Trump I feel like many older religious
Republicans were never into all of that
outright nonsense but it's really hard
to get them to question authority I hope
so I don't know the answer to that I
hope that that that the movement away
from some of these by some of these
Republicans does get voters to
reconsider but they voted for Trump they
fell for Trump and voted for him so they
don't strike me as the most nuanced and
rational people already gangster talk
has sent the $2 super check do you think
Howard Stern sucks now it was just
talking about this with some friends who
are also fans of Howard do I wish Howard
was doing more than three shows a week
with like twenty weeks of vacation a
year yes I do do I think the show is
worse now I don't care for some of these
fluffier interviews with a-list
celebrities I don't find them
interesting and I think that there's no
question a lot of the people Howard is
now interviewing are the people that 15
years ago he would have been making fun
of okay so that I am NOT a fan of and I
think has been a decline in the Howard
Stern Show at the same time Howard has
been way more direct about what are on
most issues not guns but on most issues
pretty progressive politics and it's
alienated some of those viewers but that
I actually like I actually do like that
so you know does he does Howard Stern
suck now I wish that there were more I
loved the phony phone calls song
parodies I wish that there was still
more of that
I haven't been hearing Richard and salen
the program nearly as much
where's Betelgeuse been you know I have
a lot of actually Betelgeuse was on not
that long ago but it's a different show
it's constantly changing when I started
listening when I was like 12 on the way
to school when my mom would drive me
into middle school middle school it was
a different program actually no I had a
bus to middle school so it must have
been when I was 14 in high school but
yeah you know programs change over time
the David Pakman show has changed over
time
Olivia van gada has sent the ten dollar
super chat how can hey treat male
contain both the types of errors that a
speech-to-text program might make in
other words Parkman and is of co-host
and also spelling out errors like
Argentina that could only be from an
email I never even considered that some
of the errors were a result of the use
of text-to-speech speech-to-text
programs so I can't really answer the
question I don't know I don't know how
that how that I can't answer it because
I never considered it Raymond mccabe has
sent a $2 super chat pasty Zildjian
Sabian or other I guess you're asking
about symbols and what is your favorite
drumstick okay I think I actually have
I'll just grab my favorite drumstick
right here hold on this right here is my
default wait a second what are these
this is not my favorite stick okay I do
like these these are good these are
Japanese oak Promark sticks let's see if
I can get the camera to focus on that
hmm not really
it's a 5a okay I usually play an extreme
5a the 5b is way too heavy for me don't
like the 5b so I typically play an
extreme 5a Vic Firth extreme five A's
but these white oak Japanese oh crap
remark sticks I really like and I've had
them for a while I only use these on the
practice pads so the tips are still fine
other than this one that seems to be
going flat so these should probably go
in the trash but typically so so I
really like these and then if I'm
playing jazz I like the Vader 7a which
is a very thin stick and it also has a
round tip and I like that one so those
are those are usually the sticks I go
with cater cat Nia or nya has sent a $5
super check what is your opinion on
libertarian socialist ideologies you
know I don't know that much libertarian
socialism I know about socialism and I
know about libertarianism let's see
libertarian socialism is a group of anti
authoritarian political philosophies
inside the Socialist Movement that
reject socialism as centralized state
ownership and control of the economy you
know that's difficult because depending
on what definition of socialism and
communism you're using socialism is not
state-run socialism would would suggest
a public owned enterprises and control
of the economy whereas communism would
be state-run so I already am I think the
definition is already dubious I have not
really looked into it before so I'll
check it out and see see see what I can
find out about it let's do a couple
thank-yous patreon.com slash david
pakman show patrick stall Smith has just
pledged five dollars a month patrick is
now what we call a what do we call
patrick nothing bad a double-play
a double threat he is now both a member
and a patron and I really appreciate
that Patrick very very much helped us
get to 2,000 patrons and by the way I
want to mention this and I'll get to a
member thank-yous in a second when we
get to 2500 patrons we are going to be
producing looking for the right word
create I mean they've been created but I
guess turning into videos my 75 minute
long-form lectures for my class at
Boston College that I'm teaching there's
12 long-form lectures not all of which
I've given the semesters now
/ people have expressed a lot of
interest in turning those lectures on
critical thinking and epistemology and
media literacy into YouTube videos it's
a lot of work we're talking about you
know 15 hours or more of video once we
get to 2500 patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we're gonna do that
help me grow the number of patrons if
you are somebody who has been joining
the live streams over the months and
throwing in a couple bucks here or there
consider just throwing in a dollar a
month on patreon I'm really not asking
for a lot of money what we are trying to
do is get a lot of patrons because the
more patrons we have the more likely it
is that patreon will feature us on their
front page and include us in their email
blast
about campaigns publishers you can
support and it really is a small thing
we've surveyed the audience we know that
most of the audience can do $1 a month
and I don't need most of the audience to
do it I've said it before if we can get
just three or four percent of our
audience to make a contribution at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
we basically no longer have to mention
financial need ever again so if anybody
else wants to throw in a buck please do
I will thank you profusely in just
minutes and on that note a couple new
members that I do want to thank as well
Debbie Walker has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Thank You
Debbie thank you so much
Leroy Chen Leroy Chen has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership nic
Gonzalez and Phil Forbes have also
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you thank you to all of
you for signing up membership and
patreon are major funding sources major
major funding sources for the David
Pakman show
and I really appreciate that alright
we've got more super chats and stream
lab contributions coming in let's go
first to stream labs what do we have on
stream labs I think some of our friends
are coming in here let's see where are
we
papa papa Eric Patterson sent a $25
super chat with apologies for earlier
today I don't know what Eric is
referring to you may be there
maybe I need to go through my email or
tweets or Facebook or reddit or
something $25 the new high watermark for
a single contribution for today Shawn
Keogh I think is the name it's
pronounced $1 stream Labs comm
contribution hey David do you think
we're overdue for a recession from what
I understand our economy has several
bubble markets including student loans
real estate and stocks Richard Wolffe
and others have said we had six to 18
months boy I am usually very careful
about talking about stuff like this
because I really believe that in general
economic predictions are not worth that
much but the truth is I do agree and I'm
gonna be talking about this tomorrow on
the program because I'm gonna be
recommending Robert Schiller's book the
third version of irrational exuberance
first published in the year 2000
second edition came out sometime
thereafter third edition came out in 20
2014 2015 he says and I believe and I
hope that I'm wrong that the housing
market is significantly overvalued and
in a bubble in the United States that
the stock market despite Donald Trump's
cheering that we're at 23,000 on the Dow
is overvalued and in a bubble and here's
the here's why I'm so conflicted about
talking about this I do not believe as
an investment strategy in timing the
market
my strategy is and has been for a very
long time since I was in high school and
was trading small amounts of individual
stocks and losing money by continuing to
pay Trade Commission's I believe that
the best investing strategy is one where
you are dollar cost averaging
contributing to mutual funds the lowest
possible cost mutual funds through
either Vanguard or betterment on a
regular basis with total disregard for
the value of the market that being said
I do believe that we're in a bubble and
I think that Richard Wolffe is right
that there are six to 18 months Tom
Hartman for a while had been saying that
in 20
sixteen there was gonna be a major crash
and at the time when he started talking
about that I wasn't convinced and now I
feel that it is very likely that there
is going to be a crash in the next six
to 18 months now the one thing just to
keep in mind if you are someone who just
dollar-cost average is in is that when
there are declines in the stock market
when share prices go down the hundred
bucks you might be contributing buys you
more shares and the dividends that you
get from those mutual funds buy you more
shares so that eventually when hopefully
the market goes back up although that is
not guaranteed ever you then have more
shares that can appreciate but we're
kind of digging deep here but you know
what Shawn yeah I generally do agree
with that
the most expensive es tutor has sent a
dollar stream labs.com slashed the david
pakman show contribution in Spanish
again hola OTS hello again the best way
to commit maecius cuando thesis came
easter Luke's Jonas when I ordered us so
I'm gonna translate if I translated this
literally it would be horrific but I'm
gonna tell you what what he means is
that I should know that he gets ashamed
when I call his translations abortions
estaba practica no por mucho tiempo I've
been practicing for a long time no
pienso que es una clase me Cara don't
you think this is a very expensive class
got a Maki no en de nuevo Latino and you
know Santa por la clase de español y les
Pat fantasy Essex Valley so he spent
more than a hundred bucks for Spanish
classes and for Pat sexual fantasies
okay t DPS historian has sent a $2.00
stream labs contribution I saw you paid
a Finnish composer guy for a new show
theme on patreon when do we get to hear
it I have no clue what you're talking
about
I paid I've never paid any finished
composers that I'm aware of
and I've never paid for anything to be
composed for the show and I don't know
how I would pay for the theme on
patreon or if you're saying you saw news
about that on patreon I don't know what
you're talking about but it doesn't ring
a bell at all doesn't ring a bell at all
Eric Patterson has sent a $10 stream
Labs contribution if I remember
correctly you identify as agnostic what
evidence would you require to become a
theist not meaning religious only
theistic what evidence would I need
here's the thing I am willing to be
convinced that there is a deity if I am
presented with that evidence I've never
thought hard about exactly what that
evidence would be there sometimes people
say if God's FET moves stars around to
spell out this is God believe in me then
I would believe that there is a God and
that's not my idea and I'm not saying
that that's what I would need I should
think about that I want to be super
clear my answer is not I would never
change change my mind and believe that
there is a literal God that's not my
answer I would if I was presented with
evidence I've never thought truly hard
about what that evidence would have to
be but it seems like a valuable endeavor
seems like something that would be worth
thinking about to ATZ turbo has sent a
$5 a stream Labs contribution any piece
for any plans for a long form piece on
MMT I'm a former librarian still trying
to wrap my head around the idea of the
national debt being irrelevant Oh mmm
tea is what kind of money theory is that
modern monetary theory yeah so modern
monetary theory theory suggests that the
government basically cannot become
insolvent because the debt effectively
doesn't matter and the government can
just always print more money and even if
it's devalued you're never really going
to end up with out you're not going to
end up in solvent yeah it's an
interesting topic it's more niche than
some of the other topics we've dealt
with but I'd be willing to I'd be
willing to look into that TDPS historian
has sent a dollar saying you didn't pay
for this and here is a link
a patreon Lane let's see what this is
I'm genuinely curious David Pakman show
intro song sneak peak audio posted on
April 8th what I don't even remember
what this is unlock it now I'm signing
I'm we're gonna listen to it together
let's see let me get signed in to
patreon I'm so curious what this is give
me a second here did I pay for this I
don't know oh boy now I've got to get
authenticated on patreon this is going
to take longer than I expected but I
listen this is worth it
because I want to know what this is
verifying my device here and let's see
what this theme song is yet there is a
post there called a sneak preview now I
have to log in again I couldn't possibly
tell you why man this is taking forever
let's see what is that sneak preview of
let me turn my volume up to see if we
can all hear it oh wait a second this is
not one of my posts now I I'm so
confused I see this is someone else has
posted a on their page I was so confused
someone has posted on their patreon
something that they are calling sneak
peek audio of the David Pakman show song
intro that they are charging people for
I've never paid for any music for the
show and in fact we have two new
possibilities for show music that I'm
looking at right now that we might be
using and we're not paying for any of it
people have offered to donate it so it's
possible that this person offered to
make us a song or something like that
but we've not paid for any music and
there's no plan for whatever that is
although I can't hear it because it's
locked I can't I can't I don't know what
that is but you know I don't know I'm
sorry I don't know what to tell you but
that that's not going to be that's not
going to be the theme song Yesenia
Moreno has sent a dollar stream
laughs contribution can you bring the
hey tree at male voice guy on the show
you know the agreement with the hatred
male voice guy is because he's a
professional TV radio and movie
narrator the arrangement with him is
he'll do hatred mail for us but we can
never mention who it is because his
clients don't necessarily know his
political leanings and as a result he
doesn't want it to be known that he's
this super progressive who loves the
David Pakman show
and so the agreement is we can't
identify him now maybe he would be
willing to be interviewed with no video
or something like that that might be
interesting but I think he'd be worried
that his voice you know he's doing a
voice for hatred mail he might be worth
if I were him and I didn't want to be
discovered I'd be worried that people
would figure out who he is if he used
sort of like his normal voice we have a
new a few new patrons to mention that
are really great people
Yesenia Moreno has made a $2.00 a month
pledge at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show Thank You Yesenia thank you so much
very much appreciated Linda Irene cromby
has pledged 2 bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
Thank You Linda that wasn't too painful
was it des bys has made a $2.00 a month
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show thank you as well I really really
appreciate that we have nearly 2,000
people who are now contributing on a
monthly basis on patreon we're not
asking for much even just a dollar even
just a dollar makes a big difference so
let's keep those coming in christina has
sent a dollar I was planning on wrapping
up at 10:00 p.m. Eastern in 3 minutes
but we've got so many messages I can't
leave if there are questions on super
chat right I mean the people have paid
after all
christina has sent a dollar stream lapse
contribution do you celebrate Christmas
in a secular way no I don't
I mean I'm Jewish and even though
religiously I don't really have I don't
have religious beliefs culturally and
ethnically I ident
with Judaism but and if you by the way
if you saw my DNA test I did a DNA test
two of them actually and brought on a
DNA DNA expert to analyze my DNA he said
I was the most Jewish person whose DNA
he's ever even heard of something like
97% Ashkenazi Jewish DNA and 3% noise
that might be nothing at all so no I do
not celebrate Christmas in a religious
nor secular way the holiday season's
fine I mean it's very cold here in New
England and I do like you know you've
got a couple days off we usually take
the last week of the year off altogether
so even though I don't celebrate
Christmas there's that nice period
between Christmas which is a federal
holiday religious holiday federal
holiday establishment of religion
anybody we take that week off between
Christmas and New Year's usually
depending on kind of how the day's fall
and news about that for this year
upcoming no full decision made yet Terry
Grier has sent a ten dollar super chat
with no question or comment well thanks
very much I appreciate that gangster
talk has sent a $2.00 super jet who's
got a bigger penis you're Kyle kolinsky
you know we've never compared so I
really couldn't say I've hung out with
Kyle a few times and we've got a dinner
and you know we've gotten coffee and
we've talked about many many things but
it's it might be shocking to you but
penis size has never come up Bryan
Rasmussen $5 super Chad how do you feel
about lawrence O'Donnell since he leaked
his breakdown yeah so for people who
don't know lawrence O'Donnell MSNBC host
a video leaked and who knows where it
came from and if you say if you're
saying since his leaked breakdown I see
you know I assume that a lot of the
people in corporate media are exactly
what you would imagine them to be right
the bill o'reilly let's that let's do it
live thing lawrence O'Donnell losing his
[ __ ] because of some kind of hammering
noise that was going on or something
that was wrong with his papers or
earpiece or I don't know what it was
I get the frustrations when technology
doesn't work well when you're trying to
do a show
I mean we've all experienced it
particularly in independent media but
not exactly the best look Barry Bostwick
has sent a $2.00 super chat
why doesn't vegan producer Pat say much
anymore you know a pat we have just
recently scaled up the technical
production of the show you might have
noticed that now every almost every
story in addition to just having clips
and images that we cut - we've got
b-roll video that plays while we're
talking we've added social media
elements to the daily program production
a whole bunch of stuff has been thrown
at Pat very recently and we have limited
time for prep for the show in the
morning so for the time being Pat has
been focusing his efforts on those
technical improvements and we still hear
from pat on the bonus show Pat will
chime in during lack calls whenever he
wants Pat will chime in during audience
questions when he wants and voicemails
when he wants etc but the amount of work
for Pat during some other portions of
the show has increased dramatically and
we don't want to overload Pat right so
Pat's there and our members are very
very aware of that and he'll be on the
Friday program tomorrow and we'll hear
some of his opinions about the questions
that I mentioned earlier but yeah Pat
Pat is doing well and he's there and
it's great to have him in studio every
day
Yesenia Moreno has sent a dollar stream
labs contribution at stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show asking are
you going to do more cooking videos I
want to do more cooking videos they
require quite a bit of editing and
production and setup so it's a lot of
work and we're just so busy with a
million different things right now that
it's been tough to get that done I do
want to do some live stream coffee
making I just got new bags of david
pakman show coffee and it is fantastic
it is absolutely fantastic the coffee is
available at david pakman.com slash gear
and it is roasted very close to Boston
by Patrick at blue fire Coffee Roasters
we've
an espresso blend we've got a drip
coffee blend and the bags are flying out
of here not here but out of blue fire
coffee roasters and I do want to do some
demos I want to do a chem X and French
press demo with the drip coffee blend
and that I want to throw some of the
espresso into my espresso machine and do
a couple videos there those I think will
be easier to produce than the cooking
videos so I should do that and I'm
looking forward to doing that hopefully
sooner than later
Paul lien has sent a $5 super chat with
no question or comment thank you very
much I really do appreciate that Paul
very very much appreciated all the
contributions are very much appreciated
and we have I believe one other
contribution that just came in it's kind
of hard to know sometimes whether these
are coming in oh yeah
Purple Haze oh nine cent to five dollar
question not sure if you saw my reddit
question about witnessing the end of the
Republican Party as we know it do you
think that Trump could be the best thing
that could happen to the Republican
Party by bringing out the best in them
or is it just a blip I will go back to
my comment at the beginning of the
stream which was the problem for
Republicans even if some elected
officials start to wake up to the
insanity of Trump is that their voters
were dumb or indifferent enough or bad
enough people to be bamboozled into
voting for Donald Trump and that's not
something you get a fix by a few
Republican senators coming out against
Donald Trump TDPS pat has sent the
dollar contribution boss I'll do a vegan
cooking video count on me okay very good
I assume that that was our normal
Spanish speaker Yesenia Moreno how is
the lawsuit going ah very good we were
threatened with a lawsuit this is gonna
be my last major story for tonight we
were threatened with a lawsuit for the
use of a picture two years ago four
months ago so in other words the lawsuit
threat came in maybe three four months
ago and it was for the use of a picture
in July of 2015 $5,000 was demanded from
us in a totally formulaic letter and it
was from a law firm that turns these out
and we spoke to a number of lawyers
about it they were asking for five grand
they were threatening to sue us for a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and I
can now report to you that we have
settled the case for a few hundred bucks
okay and the fact that it was settled
for a few hundred bucks confirms to me
that there was a lot of fear-mongering
going on but that there was really no
good chance of collecting anything close
to that amount of mony because if you
are asking for five grand and
threatening a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar lawsuit based on triple damages
on statutory malicious copyright
infringement why would you go away for a
few hundred bucks
after I forced them by corresponding
with email after email after email to
invest endless hours of attorney time
into dealing with me so I would call it
a success and the reason I even offered
any money was that our attorneys that I
spoke to said listen David you can fight
this and there's a good chance that you
could win it the problem is if you get
sued in federal court for copyright
infringement you're probably not going
to want to represent yourself and the
risk is too great try to settle it for a
few hundred bucks so even though I've
admitted to no guilt or wrongdoing I
have settled and we were able to pay a
few hundred bucks and make a threat of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar
lawsuit go away gangster talk has sent a
$2.00 super check could you beat Kyle
kolinsky in a fist fight couldn't tell
you don't plan to find out Luka blight
69 cent a five-dollar super chat don't
always agree with you politically and
socially but belated congratulations on
four hundred thousand subscribers you're
still someone I consider worth listening
to thank you so much Courtney Haines $2
keep up the good work thank you Jean
Sebastian with a twenty Mexican dollar
super chat the u.s. did not qualify for
the FIFA World Cup
sad yeah I know that that I noticed that
and I could not care less I don't follow
American soccer I follow the Argentinian
men's national team and just barely just
barely the Argentinian men's national
team qualified for the World Cup so
that's good I completely disagree with
the World Cup being held in Russia I
completely disagree with the World Cup
being held in Qatar but I love that
Argentinian men's national team I was
born in Argentina just so people don't
think I'm just a bandwagon or jumping on
the Leo Messi bandwagon and I am looking
forward to watching the games although
not the politics and corruption of the
World Cup Eric Patterson sent the $10
super chant how often do you swear
thinking of Luis on the bonus shows of
the past
I really don't swear that often in my
personal life I really don't swear that
often and yeah that's about it let me
give a couple shoutouts to the top
donors of all time via stream lab stream
Labs keeps track something I wish
YouTube super chat did stream Labs keeps
track of all contributions forever and
the number one contributor in terms of
dollar amount is Eric Patterson with two
hundred and fifty four dollars
contributed in second place is Clark one
two three four now you might be saying
David wait a second
Clark one two three four that's not
ringing a bell that's because cloth one
two three four contributes under five or
six at least different handles with $69
69 cents and Christina in third place
with 41 dollars in contributions now in
terms of number of contributions
Christina takes the cake with 33
contributions Clark one two three four
in second place with 29 contributions
and then a user going by the name of
Nitin Pakman who I can assure you is not
really my brother and Eric Patterson
tied in third place for with seven
contributions over the life of the
stream labs platform so very very
exciting stuff and on that note that's
the end of this live stream thanks to
everybody who joined me make a patreon
pledge patreon.com slash david pakman
show let's do it let's get the two
thousand patrons